it's hard to believe my friends but
Donald Trump glitching badly at a recent
speech in Washington D.C
suggesting more crimes if he were to be
elected president of the United States a
second time this was again at some kind
of religious event in Washington DC over
the weekend here Donald Trump says if he
becomes president he will deny entry to
the United States to Communists and
marxists is this potentially legal I'll
tell you in a moment listen to what the
failed former president twice indicted
twice impeached had to say to a
disgusting sycophant crowd made them
competitive today I'm announcing a new
plan to protect the Integrity of our
immigration system federal law prohibits
the entry of Communists and
totalitarians into the United States
[Applause]
that are already here that grew up in it
I think we have to pass a new law for
them
using federal law in section
212 F of the immigration and nationality
act I will order my government to deny
entry to all Communists and all marxists
wow wow
quite an idea
those who come to and join our country
must love our country we want them to
love our country we don't want them when
they want to destroy our country welcome
to America we want to destroy your
country thank you very much so we're
going to keep foreign Christian hating
Communists marxists and socialists out
of America all right so you get the idea
keep communist marxists and socialists
out of the United States also equating
being a socialist to hating America
there's many socialists who like America
in the same way that there's many people
who think gun laws should be more
permissive who like America just because
you want something to be different
doesn't mean you hate America but what
Trump is proposing is almost certainly
against the law and impossible from a
practical perspective it's against the
law because Trump's idea would violate
the First Amendment of the United States
Constitution it protects freedom of
speech religion press assembly and
petition communism and Marxism are
political ideologies that people have
the right to express and they have the
right to believe in them as long as they
are not advocating for violence or an
overthrow of the government they are
allowed to believe those things it is
also against the law because it would
violate the equal protection Clause of
the 14th Amendment which prohibits
discrimination based on race ethnicity
national origin or other arbitrary
criteria communism and Marxism and
socialism are not inherent traits of any
ethnic or racial group they are
movements and they are quite complex
movements by the way which have
followers from different backgrounds in
different countries it's impossible from
a practical perspective to do this
because there's no clear or objective
way to define who is a communist or a
Marxist there are many different
branches in schools and interpretations
of Communism and Marxism some are
contradictory some are incompatible with
each other and there are also many
people who just like one aspect of
Communism or Marxism like uh if for
example are you a communist if you want
to nationalize the airlines I don't know
you you can't come to the U.S on that
basis are you a Marxist if you believe
in the labor theory of value
doesn't make any sense and that's why
it's impossible from a practical
perspective how can you reliably screen
or monitor people's political beliefs at
the border and do you think for a second
that those who say governments
incompetent everybody's incompetent they
now want to deputize immigrations and
Customs Enforcement to quiz individuals
about the political beliefs and
determine if they are communistic
socialistic or Marxist it's insane and
ridiculous and almost certainly against
the law which makes it a perfect
proposal for Donald Trump couple other
clips from this ridiculous speech Trump
also said that on day one of his
presidency he will again try to ban
trans people from the military
and on day one I will reinstate the
Trump ban on transgenders in the
military wow
because our Warriors should be focused
on crushing American enemies on being
strong on having the image of being
strong they have to be powerful they
have to be strong especially when you
see what's happening in the world today
yeah so first of all as usual the
biggest Applause line during Trump's
entire speech when what it was when he
said he would ban trans people from the
military think of how crazy that is
though men are allowed in the military
okay nobody denies that women are
allowed in the military I don't think
anyone denies that even though there are
people on the right who don't like that
so why would you ban trans people if men
and women are allowed in the military
why on Earth would you ban trans people
and of course
we have a number of studies about this
and it makes no sense to ban trans
people from the military Trump did the
entire thing about yes I'm a victim but
really this is about you saying he is
being invited for them whatever that
means every time the radical
s Marxist Communists and fascists indict
me I consider it a great Badge of
Courage
right
okay
[Applause]
I'm being indicted for you and I believe
the you is more than 200 million people
that love our country they're out there
yeah
um as as usual we don't know exactly
what these numbers mean 200 million
people Trump has said he has hundreds of
millions of supporters in the country uh
he doesn't certainly even if you assume
that he has twice as many supporters as
the number that voted for him that still
puts it at 150 million or or under and I
think we all know that the number is
actually quite small much smaller than
that but this is part of the grift the
way he grifts money on indictments which
he's doing will maybe we'll look at some
fundraising emails he sent maybe we
won't we probably won't actually I'll
just tell you he's sending out grifty
fundraising emails and part of the
reason that he's doing it is he has come
up with this storyline of they're really
going after you when they go after me
it's part of the victimhood complex and
then lastly here Trump again misstating
the law about classified documents
claiming he just there's no crime and he
could do whatever he wanted with the
documents
well it is true
I mean it is true
in other words whatever documents the
president decides to take with him he
has the absolute right to take them
really he has the absolute right to keep
them or he can give them back to Nara if
he wants he talks to them like we were
doing and he can do that if he wants
that's the law and it couldn't be more
clear okay so as Democratic Congressman
Daniel Goldman explained on Twitter this
is an argument that should be blocked
from even being made during Donald
Trump's trial because it is a false
representation of the law one of the
things you're not allowed to do in a
defense is to misstate what the law is
the judge will instruct the jury as to
what the law is and uh the special
counsel prosecutors will likely move to
preclude Trump from making this argument
in court because it is simply not what
the law says this is a TV argument that
Trump is making this is a PR argument
this is a grift argument that Trump is
making it is not actually what the law
says so another weekend
another completely unhinged and
dangerous speech from the failed former
president let's now look at what's
happening with polling in the 2024
Republican primary when you're using
websites and apps your device sends out
data about you into the open who you are
where you go things you like that data
then gets sold around for advertising
purposes which is why every time I
connect to the internet I use a VPN to
hide my IP address and our sponsor
private internet access is the most
trustworthy VPN on the market it's the
only VPN that has proven multiple times
in court they don't log your activity
private internet access protects you
from the prying eyes of hackers your
internet service provider tech companies
private internet access is also super
fast for streaming and for downloads you
can watch your favorite streaming
platforms as if you're in another
country like the UK to access cool new
content and with just one account you
can protect unlimited devices all at the
same time this is really a game changer
private internet access is giving my
audience 83 percent off that's 203 a
month plus four months free go to Pia
vpn.com Pacman the link is down below